are you excited to announce best picture
oscar goes to
okay coda
the independent film coda was the
underdog winner of the best picture
oscar breaking new ground as the first
film produced by a streaming service to
win best picture and with its mostly
deaf cast including troy kutzer who made
history as the first deaf man to win an
oscar for best supporting
actor i just wanted to say that this is
dedicated to the deaf community
the coda community and the disabled
community this is our moment
this is an extermination dune won the
most awards with six
g.i james ii can't wait to see it all
right
but the talk of the night was when actor
will smith punched comedian chris rock
over a joke about smith's wife's hair
wow
will smith just smack the [ __ ] out of me
jada pinkett smith has alopecia a
medical condition that causes hair loss
then a visibly shaken smith won best
actor for his work in king richard
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to my all my fellow
nominees
in this business you got to be able to
have
people disrespecting you
and you gotta smile and you gotta
pretend like that's okay
it was awkward it was sensational it was
dramatic and though it was unplanned it
may have been just the thing that the
oscars producers needed to make this
show buzzworthy once again this was the
first year that the oscars have returned
to the historic dolby theater since the
pandemic and the producers have been
desperate trying to find a way to get
back those lost viewers
thank you kevin that was very dramatic
other notable wins jane campion became
the third woman in film history to win
the best director prize and ariana
debose became the first openly queer
woman of color to win best supporting
actress
even in this weary world that we live in
dreams do come true
the oscars attempted to recognize the
suffering in ukraine with a moment of
silence and ukrainian-born actress mila
kunis who's helped raise 35 million
dollars for ukrainian refugees briefly
addressed what she called recent global
events
one cannot help but be in awe of those
who find strength to keep fighting
through unimaginable darkness people in
florida we're gonna have a gay night the
show was overall fun and light as the
producers had promised with three funny
women moving things along it was a night
hollywood shines once more and where
drama was in spades heidi joe castro al
jazeera los angeles